Now we are ready to put the genome
assembly problem into the language of
computer scientists.
Let's try to formalize this problem.
So the genome sequencing problem: input is
a collection of string.
Output is a string, Genome, constructed
from reads.
Is it a well formalized problem?
Let's ask Pavel! Last time, remember
in the replication chapter, I
cricitized Pavel for not giving a well
defined problem.
Now let's ask him.
Well this is not a computational problem.
Okay, so allow me to first define what is
k-mer composition of a string.
Given a string, a k-mer composition of a
string
is a set of all k-mers in that string.
So we can order the k-mers in this order,
according to the positions where they
appear in the genome.
But please note that the position
information is not available.
So a more correct way to order these
k-mers is
in a lexicographic order, like in the
dictionary.
The string reconstruction problem:
Input: a collection of k-mers.
Output: a genome such that the k-mer
composition of
the genome is equal to the collection of
k-mers.
So we have a well-defined problem.
And what next is to build intuitions
and algorithms to solve this problem.
What is the most natural way to
solve this?
Well, let's start with TAA
and assume that this is the first 3-mer
of the genome.
If TAA is the first k-mer of the genome,
then what is the second k-mer?
The second k-mer should start with AA.
This one k-mer starting with AA, that is
AAT.
Then what is the next k-mer?
The next k-mer should start with AT.
Here, we have three AT, but they are all
ATG, so we choose one.
What is the next k-mer?
The next k-mer should start with TG.
Here we have three k-mers starting with
TG.
Which one would we choose?
I don't know.
Let's pick a random one.
Okay, so the next k-mer should start with
GT.
Here we have one k-mer starting with GT.
And the next one TT.
So the next k-mer should start with
TT.
But in our collection there's no k-mer
starting with TT.
Well then certainly there is a need
to develop new algorithms for solving this
problem.